hey what's going on folks there's
something I want to go over with you
guys today that you should find and be
pretty interesting if you are new to the
game of Thrones community I don't want
to assume all of you watch every YouTube
video and read every single thing online
about the show like some people do so to
most of you this may be new information
and if you have been a part of the
community for quite some time now and
you do read and watch everything about
the show then you probably already are
aware of this so I do apologize to you
guys you might want to go back and just
watch one of my other videos if you
haven't seen them all yet but personally
I am new to the game of Thrones
community and I just came across this
about a month or two ago so I thought it
was very interesting to see how the
story may have actually turned out so I
want to read this to you guys that don't
know about this and hopefully you can
enjoy it as much as I did when I first
read it basically what happened was back
in 1993 before George finished any of
his books he sent out a small outline of
those books just given some small
details about some of the key players
and key things that were going to take
place in the story and he initially
intended the story to be epic trilogy
just three books and we know that of
course that has changed over the years
and I'll tell you right up front a good
bit of the things in his outline have
changed but I think it's still pretty
cool to see where he saw the story going
when he originally had the idea for it
so I'm going to read to you the three
pages that George sent out back in 1993
explaining what his story was and how it
was going to take shape and I'm going to
warn you there are still some potential
spoilers in this so proceed with caution
and also just want to say whoever first
took the picture of this and posted it
online
however long ago there was a glare on
some of the pages so a few of the words
are hard to make out so I apologize if a
few of the sentences sound a little
broken but I'll do my best to try to
read it anyway so let's begin
it says here are the first 13 chapters
of the high fantasy novel I promised you
which I'm calling a game of Thrones and
one completed this will be the first
volume and what I see as an epic trilogy
with the overall title a Song of Ice and
Fire and as you know I don't outline my
novels I find that if I know exactly
where a book is going I lose all
interest in writing it I do however have
some strong notions as to the overall
structure of the story that I am telling
in the eventual fate of many of the
principal characters in the drama
roughly speaking there are three major
conflicts set in motion in the chapters
enclosed these will form the major plot
threads of the trilogy the first threat
is between the Great Houses of Lannister
and Stark and as it plays out in a cycle
of plot counter plot ambition murder and
revenge with the Iron Throne of the
Seven Kingdoms as the ultimate prize
this will form the backbone of the first
volume of the trilogy a game of Thrones
and while the line of Lannister and the
direwolf of Starks snarl and scrap
however a second and greater threat
takes shape across the Narrow Sea where
the Dothraki horselord master barbarian
hordes for a great invasion of the Seven
Kingdoms led by the fierce and beautiful
Daenerys Stormborn the last of the
Targaryen dragons
the Dothraki invasion will be the
central story of my second volume a
dance with dragons but the greatest
danger of all however comes from the
north from the icy wastes beyond the
wall where half forgotten
demons out of legend the inhuman others
raise cold legions of the undead and
then never born and prepare to ride down
on the winds of winter to extinguish
everything that we would call life the
only thing that stands between the Seven
Kingdoms and an endless night is the
wall and a handful of men and black
called the Nights Watch their story will
be the heart of my third volume the
winds of winter the final battle will
also draw together characters and plot
threads left from the first two books
and resolved all in one huge climax the
13 chapters on hand should give you a
notion as to my narrative strategy all
three books will feature a complex
mosaic of intercutting points of view
among various of my large and diverse
cast of players the cast will not always
remain the same
old characters will die and new ones
will be introduced some of the
fatalities will include sympathetic
viewpoint characters I want the reader
to feel that no one is ever completely
safe not even the characters who seem to
be the heroes the suspense always
ratchets up a notch when you know that
any character can die at any time and as
certainly agree with that what I love
about this story so much is that any
character can die even the main
characters you just never know what's
going to happen and I certainly love
that aspect of this story five central
characters will make it through all
three volumes however going from
children to adults and changing the
world in themselves in a process in a
sense my trilogy is almost a
generational saga telling the life
stories of these five characters three
men and two women the five key players
are Tyrion Lannister Daenerys Targaryen
and three of the children of Winterfell
Arya bran and the bastard Jon Snow all
of them are introduced at some length
and the chapters you have on hand and
hopefully this is going to be quite an
epic epic in its scale epic in its
action and epic in its length
I see all three volumes as big books
running about 700 to 800 manuscript
pages so things are just barely getting
underway in the 13 chapters that I have
sent you I have quite a clear notion of
how the story is going to unfold in the
first volume a game of Thrones things
will get a lot worse for the poor Starks
before they get better
I'm afraid Lord Eddard Stark and his
wife Catelyn Kali are both doomed and
will perish at the hands of their
enemies Ned will discover what happened
to his friend Jon Arryn and this is
where it kinda is unclear to read but it
basically says Joffrey will not be
sympathetic and Ned will be accused of
treason but before he is taken he will
help his wife and daughter Arya escape
back to Winterfell each of the
contending families will long and has a
member of dubious loyalty in its myths
Sansa Stark wedded Joffrey Baratheon
will bear him a son the heir to the
throne and when the crunch comes she
will choose her husband and child over
her parents and siblings a choice she
will later bitterly regret
Tyrion Lannister meanwhile will would-be
friend both Sansa and her sister Arya
while growing more and more disenchanted
with his own family and young brain will
come out of his coma after a strange
prophetic dream only to discover that he
will never walk again
and he will turn to magic at first in
the hope of restoring his legs but later
for his own sake
and when his father Edward Stark is
executed brain will see the shape of
doom descending on all of them but
nothing he can say will stop his brother
Rob from calling the banners in
rebellion all of the North will be
inflamed by war and Robb will win
several splendid victories and maim
Joffrey Baratheon on the battlefield but
in the end he will not be able to stand
against Jaime and Tyrion Lannister and
their allies Robb Stark will die in
battle and Tyrion Lannister will besiege
and burn Winterfell Jon Snow the bastard
will remain in a far north
he will mature into a ranger of great
daring and ultimately will succeed his
uncle as the commander of the Nights
Watch and when winter fo burns Catelyn
Stark will be forced to flee with her
son bran and her daughter Arya and
wounded by the Lannister riders they
will seek refuge at the wall but the men
of the Nights Watch give up their
families when they take the black and
join and benjin will not be able to help
to Jon's anguish it will lead to a
bitter estrangement between Jon and bran
Arya will be more forgiving until she
realizes with terror that she has fallen
in love with Jon who is not only her
half-brother but a man of the Nights
Watch who has sworn to celibacy and
their passion will continue to torment
Jon and Arya throughout the trilogy
until the secret of Jon's true parentage
is finally revealed in the last book I
think that's pretty damn interesting
before George even had the first book
finished he already knew he was going to
do this or plus L equals J thing that's
genius if you ask me and abandoned by
the Nights Watch Catelyn and her
children will find their only hope of
safety lies even further north beyond
the wall where they fall into the hands
of Mance Rayder the king-beyond-the-wall
and get a dreadful glimpse of the
inhuman others as they attack the wildly
encampment brands magic Arya sword
needle and the savagery of their dire
woes will help them survive but their
mother Catelyn will die at the hands of
the others and over across the Narrow
Sea Daenerys Targaryen will discover
that her new husband the Dothraki Khal
Drogo has little interest in invading
the Seven Kingdoms much to her brother's
frustration and when Viserys presses his
claims past a point of wisdom Khal Drogo
will finally grow annoyed and kill him
out of hand eliminating the Targaryen
pretender and
daenerys as the last of her line and
danerys will bite her time but she will
not forget and when the moment is right
she will kill her husband to avenge her
brother and then flee with a trusted
friend into the wilderness beyond vas
Dothrak and this is where kind of gets
hard to read again but it basically says
she stumbles onto her dragon eggs and
then she begins to plan for her invasion
of the Seven Kingdoms and lastly it says
Tyrion Lannister will continue to travel
to plot and to play the game of Thrones
finally removing his nephew Joffrey and
disgust at the boy Kings brutality Jaime
Lannister will follow Joffrey on the
throne of the Seven Kingdoms by the
simple expedient of killing everyone
ahead of him in the line of succession
and blaming his brother Tyrion for the
murders exiled Tyrion will change sides
making his common cause with the
surviving Starks to bring his brother
down and falling helplessly in love with
Arya Stark while he's at it
his passion is unreciprocated but no
less intents for that and it will lead
to a deadly rivalry between Terry and
Jon Snow
but that's the second book I hope you
will find some editors who are excited
about all of this as I am
feel free to share this letter with
anyone who wants to know how the story
will go all best george RR martin so how
do you guys feel about his original
story arc i think some of this is pretty
damn interesting if you ask me like
Sansa and Joffrey having a baby together
or Rob killing Joffrey on the
battlefield that's pretty cool I'd like
to see a stark actually kill Joffrey
with their own hands I think that'd have
been beautiful to see especially on the
show and it says Tyrion burns down
Winterfell and then Tyrion plots against
Jaime Jaime blames Tyrion for some
murders Catelyn goes north of the wall
and gets killed by a white Walker that's
pretty damn cool I know most of this
stuff has changed but tell me what you
guys think about this do you like the
original story or do you like some of
this other stuff that was changed I
wouldn't have mine seeing a few of these
things actually still take place in the
story or at least on the show to where
you could actually visualize it taking
place and it also says Dany kills Khal
Drogo to avenge her brother it's pretty
damn interesting that's a complete 180
from how she really felt so let me know
too
guys think about this I thought it was
pretty damn cool when I first read it
even sitting here reading and again I
kind of forgot about some of this stuff
and I still think it's pretty cool
just to see where George's mind was at
when he first had a taste of how he was
going to do this story I think it's very
interesting I think it's genius that he
was able to map out most of the story
before he even finished one novel that's
pretty damn cool when it just shows you
how brilliant he is so let me know guys
thanks for watching thanks for listening
I will see you guys next time bye